في الثامن والعشرين من فبراير من كل عام
يحتفل العالم باليوم العالمي للامراض
النادره في سبيل توعيه الافراد بسبل
الوقايه والعلاج في حاله تشخيص المبكر
منظمات والصحه العالميه تحصين نحو سبعه
الاف مرض نادر في العالم لا يعاني منه
اكثر من 7% من سكان العالم فقط نسبه 80%
من هذه الامراض هي من اصل جيني حيث تسجل
حاله واحده من بين ثلاثه الاف نسمه ما
يفسر تسميتها بالنادره تعد هذه الامراض
خطيره ومعيقه حيث غالبا ما تظهر خلال
المراحل الاولى من حياه الطفوله وتتسبب في
وفاه نسبه 30% من هذه الشريحه حسب منظمه
الصحه العالميه
الامراض النادره غالبا ما تكون مزمنه
وتتطور ويزداد المرض مع مرور الوقت وتحدث
للمريض انتكاسات صحيه متكرره هناك ما
يراوح بين 6,08000 نوع من الامراض النادره
75% من هذه الامراض النادره يصيب الاطفال
و 30% من المرض من المرضى بمرض نادر
يموتون قبل سن الخامسه 80% من الامراض
النائره اسبابها وراثيه هناك انواع كثيره
من الامراض النادره تشمل الامراض النفسيه
امراض القلب والاوعيه الدمويه
الكروموسومات الامراض الجلديه العدوى
الغدد الصماء وامراض العظام بعضها لها
اسماء معروفه للعامه واخرى تحمل اسم
الطبيب المكتشف لها او حتى تنسب لاول مريض
او اول مستشفى تم اكتشاف المرض به كثير من
الامراض النادره ليس لها علاجات وكثير
منها لم يتم حتى دراسته بابحاث طبيه حتى
الان وفي كثير من الاحيان عن الاشخاص
المصابين بمرض النادر من عدم القدره على
التشخيص الدقيق او عدم ت وافر ادويه
مناسبه لعلاجه
[موسيقى]
في الاستوديو تنضم الينا الطبيب وعلمت
الجينات ومؤسسه ورئيسه مركز الشيخ زايد
الابحاث الجينيه دكتوره مريم مطر دكتوره
يسعد صباحك نورتنا صباح العربيه من جديد
طيب دكتور عندما نتحدث عن 7000 مرض نادر
عالميا ماذا عن منطقتنا العربيه ولماذا
تعتبر هذه الامراض نادره بين البشر اكيد
اول شيء تعريفا للامراض النادره مثل ما
ذكرت فتنه ان هو مرض يصاب فيه تقريبا كل
بين كل عشره الاف نسمه واحد وكان يصاب فيه
وسميت الامراض النادره لقله عدد الناس
المصابين فيها ولكن مع الابحاث عرفنا انه
العدد مش قليل ولكن الكشف المبكر هو اللي
ياخر اكتشافهم اكتشاف هاي الحالات اما
بالنسبه لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وهذه صراحه
الادراك ما كان موجود قبل عشر سنوات زالت
زاد الادراك لما بدينا نسوي الفحوصات
الجينيه وصارت متوفره للجميع وفي كل بقاع
الارض عرفنا ان كل اقليم على كوكب الارض
امراض نادره خاصه فيه يعني على سبيل
المثال مثل مرض
السيكل سيل اللي هي الانيميا المنجليه هذه
وحده من الامراض الشائعه في الشرق الاوسط
ولكن نادره في دول اخرى مثل امريكا
وبريطانيا عشان شي صار في وعي اكثر ان كل
اقليم يكون عنده قائمته الخاصه اللي تعنى
بالامراض النادره على سبيل المثال مثلا
مثل الامراض معينه موجود عندنا في دوله
الامارات مثل ارتفاع الكوليسترول العائلي
هاي تعتبر كانت من الامراض النادره ولكن
اليوم من خلال البحث اللي اجري من قبل
جامعه ام القرى في السعوديه شفنا تقريبا
سته وتلاتين بالمئه من العينه اللي دخلت
معانا في البحث كانت مصابه بهذه الطفره
الجينيه فبالتالي كل قائمه قاعده تتغير عن
العمره ودكتوره مريم ايضا ننوه للمشاهدين
بانه ترتدي الملابس ذات الالوان للتوعيه
بالامراض النادره في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
يعني هذه الالوان ودلالتها هي الوان تكون
فرحه من الو الطيف الجميله التي تعنى
بالوردي والاخضر واليوم انا حاولت قدر
الامكان اني اعكس هذا الجانب وهذا نوع من
الوعي ويمكن بكل تواضع انا اتشرف اني انا
امثل المفوضيه الدوليه للامراض النادره في
الامم المتحده امثل منطقه الشرق الاوسط
والبحر المتوسط وهذا يعطيني مسؤوليه لرفع
الوعي وخاصه من خلال تفعيل السياسات اللي
ارد يتم اعتمادها او القيام
باقتراحات للسياسات معينه تحمي هذه للفئه
وتوفر لهم خدمات العلاجيه في دوله
الامارات العربيه المتحده احنا نعتبر
الدوله الاولى في المنطقه اللي يتم فيها
اعتماد الادويه للامراض النادره مجرد ما
تعتمد في امريكا يتم اعتمادها في دوله
الدكتوره مريم هل هذه الامراض متوارثه
يعني اذا تابعنا تسلسل الجيني للشخص
بنلاقي انه في حدا بعيلته نصاب بهذا المرض
قبل 50 100 سنه مثلا ولا لا 80% من هذه
الامراض تعتبر امراض جينيه وراثيه والمؤلم
اكثر قلبك ان هذه للاطفال متوسط عمرهم
يعني 70% منهم يعيشون فقط لمده خمس سنوات
عشان كذا تشوفين ما في كثير من الابحاث
الدراسات عشان نترك عدد المصابين وفتره
معيشتهم تكون متوسطه يعني اليوم بس اذكركم
كلنا سمعنا عن قصه اليس في بلاد العجايب
اليوم في مرض نادر اسمه اليس في بلاد
العجائب واحنا نظن انه كاتب الروايه اللي
كتبها في
1900 كان مصاب بهذا المرض اللي يخليه يشوف
الاشياء صغيره الحجم ويعطيه هذه المخيله
الكبيره طيب دكتوره قلتي انه المشكله ليست
في المرض النادر ولكن في الكشف المبكر وفي
الجينات هل الكشف المبكر عن هذه الامراض
النادره عن هذه الجينات يقي الجنين او يقي
البشر من هذه الامراض اكيد هو التحدي
الاكبر التشخيص المبكر لهاي الحالات يعني
تخيلي يا الغالي اكثر من 30% من هذه
العينه ما يتم تشخيصه الا بعد خمس سنوات
ويكون دائما متاخر لقله عدد الكفاءه
المتخصصه في الكشف المبكر وملاحظه خلنا
نقول العلامات الحمراء اللي تدل على هذا
الشيء ولكن ما اعتقد انه التكنولوجيا
الحمد لله اليوم البشاير كثيره اليوم صارت
الدول تعنى بخارطه جينيه وهذه سهلت علينا
ان احنا نكتشفهم مبكرا وتوفير الخدمات
الوقائيه اللي اليوم تعداد
الخليج العربي اكثر من 60% عددنا اقل من
30 سنه وهذه تعطي فرصه جميله جدا لتحسين
جوده الاجيال
بس اليوم لاي حد كمان في مجتمعاتنا
العربيه مشكله زواج الاقارب كمان عم بتزيد
متعقد قصه الامراض النادره اقدر اختلف
ويايات في هذا الشيء اليوم وفي الوطن
العربي الشباب العربي ما تتخيلين كيف عنده
وعي عنده ادراك وعنده مسؤوليه قام صار
عندهم انتباه ان الشاب العربي والشاب حتى
قبل ما يتقدم له الشخص هي تروح تعمل
فحوصات دينيه وتاخذ تاريخ عائلي الشباب
العربي يعني جميل الغاليه من الوعي
والادراك وفي القمه الحكوميه اللي صارت في
دوله الامارات في دبي شفنا هذا الاشراق
اللي يطلع من دهن الشاب العربي والطموح
الكبير
والمسؤوليه اللي يدركها على مستوى الصحي
او حتى المستوى الاجتماعي الجميل وجودك
شكرا جزيلا